[Music]
hi guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
it is uh time to almost hit the road
what is it
uh it will be when this comes out the
17th and 18th
patreon 17th and uh
and then uh for youtube the 18th
and the next weekend after that i am
starting i am going back i already did
phoenix but i'm going i'll have my sec
my um out of state shows
i did uh i'm going to dallas grand uh
st prairie grand grand what the [ __ ]
grand st prairie too many words in that
yeah
so we're doing that tickets at
chrisley.com it's basically dale i say
dallas because grand st prairie uh takes
two lights a mouthful right um that's
like the movie the englishman that went
up a hill but came down a mountain they
got the nerve to [ __ ] name it that
the hugh graham movie the englishman who
went up a hill but came down a mountain
the nerve dude and also the nerve but
also
so [ __ ] like in your face symbolic
they should have just called that movie
symbolism
um
the englishman who went up a hill but
came down a mountain
when that when i first heard that
preview i was like oh this [ __ ] title
when does it stop
um
just call it the englishman right
much more palatable um so
i started uh
i'm doing dallas and then i'm doing uh
wichita
and i can't get it out of my head that
every time i say wichita i go with
wichita where the bb take bt
btk killer was
stationed like he's a [ __ ] um what do
you call it
army guy uh no but uh wichita and then i
got uh atlanta
and then i got
savannah georgia i've got washington d.c
the dar
center or whatever the [ __ ] it's called
and um
it doesn't really work as a what do you
call it the letters all together
d-a-r-dar kind of sounds like something
that somebody really dumb would say
there
dar
uh and then savannah and then uh
peoria
boston
i got a bunch of different dates so go
to crystallia.com
and uh figure that out oh great this is
[ __ ] it all up um and so
that and then also we got the life
ripped [ __ ] out you know we got this
we got this [ __ ] the periwinkle shits
um and uh because fall is coming man get
them hoodies uh we got the life rips
worldwide we got all that [ __ ] and then
different shirts and hats and we've got
the new whatever it is what it is go
[ __ ] peruse chris leah.com uh for
ticket uh tour dates and [ __ ] i'm adding
also other shows so anyway dude
um i'm back by the way i was out of town
this past weekend i was in the um
what do you call it
i was in seattle i was close to seattle
it was like wood wood woodland or wood
woodbridge wood something
some [ __ ] wood thing
and uh i was doing it for my cousin's
wedding my cousin got married
and um it was a beautiful thing now
he's 30 i think because it's 12 years
younger than me he's 30 and he got
married he wore a [ __ ] nice blue suit
he was killing it looking real handsome
and uh he's got really long hair like
[ __ ] jason mamoa and um and i and i
and he texted me like his outfit like
his tux when he went to his suit
whatever when he was gonna get married
and i wrote i can't believe you wait
until the last
and i tucked them back i can't wait i
can't believe you're waiting till the
last [ __ ]
minute
you're waiting so long to get [ __ ] uh
get your haircut before your wedding
because like it was like obviously you
gotta cut your hair for your wedding
because it's too long so that's a little
family humor for you guys um just a
little family fumer a little family
humor just joking around um and uh and
he laughed you know what i mean and then
he said really thank you so much for
coming to the wedding and i said who's
this so you know just a little family
humor you know and he said that always
gets me and i go out you know it's
beautiful um so yeah so we had a good we
had a good time we were up there you
know took the whole family up there the
whole family uh meeting my dad and my
mom and everybody just kristen and my my
my son went up there put him in a little
suit and uh dude i was just [ __ ] we
were in the middle of a
a field i don't even know it was like
called like the wedding place or some
[ __ ] we we got an airbnb now whoopsie
daisy my mom got it now whoopsie daisy
was too far away but it's all good now
it was too far away but it's all good it
was too far away from the [ __ ]
wedding and it's all good whoopsie daisy
but my mom dude this is [ __ ] going
down yes dude it keeps going down yes
dude it's like a it's like a [ __ ]
bone dog when it's done you know what
i'm talking about and it keeps on kind
of [ __ ] yeah man i don't like it
gotta move over a little bit
back and to the left back
and to the left back
and to the left
like [ __ ] that movie jfk
uh so what was i talking about [ __ ] yeah
i went to um
for the audio listeners the microphone
was going down and it was doing it like
a bone doggy i'm not sure if i could say
the word b-o-n-e blank you know what
comes next because i don't know if
they'll age restrict me on the [ __ ]
youtube shits because they do that when
you say stuff about penises but you can
say penis so it's all good man anyway
nothing sexual just talking science
back to the seattle thing or woodland or
where the hooker was so i was there
um and uh
hell yeah dude we're keeping it real
like this so i was there doing it and uh
my mom got an airbnb now it was an hour
away from the rehearsal dinner yes she
did it too far and it was an hour and 15
minutes away from the wedding yes and it
was too far and i said now mom why did
you get it so far she said because it's
closer to aunt michelle and uncle mike
it's 15 minutes away from them and i
said oh really that's cool but why did
you get it close to them he said so we
could be near them did we even see them
once in the trip at their house no so
did it make sense [ __ ] no dude but can i
get mad at my mom without getting in
trouble no yes dude
it's deeper and no matter what i do if i
pipe up to mommy i get my ass handed to
me a yes
[Music]
so we chill
and we hang out in woodland and
woodbridge or where the [ __ ] we were and
i took pictures of [ __ ] different
beautiful things it's very green out
there calvin wanted to run all over in
the poison ivy uh he fell in something
that looked like poison ivy i waited
about a day wasn't sure if it was poor
snivy it wasn't poison ivy one for chris
zero for nature um so
my son didn't get poison ivy or he's
immune maybe he's an x-man and um and
and we were there and we got to the
airbnb it looked beautiful from the
outside from the inside the bones were
[ __ ] stupid
the bones of the house were stupid yay
and my mom was complaining about the
bones of the house yay
dude mom was like oh i don't like the
bones of this house but you know it
could be beautiful
yeah
my mom talked so much during the [ __ ]
and then we did directions dude and i
had to drive yeah dude they sucked me
into driving yay
oh man because my dad's getting up there
my dad's getting up there my mom's
getting up there
they're in their mid-70s now technically
and we were too far away so we had to
[ __ ] do it on google maps and the
[ __ ] guy first of all my dad has the
english guy do the directions which is
so weird
just use the person that comes with the
[ __ ]
every [ __ ] buddy on google always has
the lady that's just like take a left on
robertson but my dad's just like a
[ __ ] dude you're gonna you're gonna
pass the first line and then you go to
the second line you're gonna take a
right
allow governor
and i'm like dad why did you change it
and of course you didn't answer the
first time yes
yes i'm driving i'm driving and i
[ __ ] said dad why didn't you chan why
did you change it oh and he didn't
answer the first time yes and i was loud
enough dude
and so i said dad why didn't why did you
change it and he said the most my dad
should ever do it he said because i like
it better
not good enough be more specific we got
an hour to get to the [ __ ] place why
we're so far away
we were so far away dude and kristen
goes up to get ready for bed because i
was downstairs what i used to call
downstairs daddy yoon when i was a kid
it was one of my first words so i was
daddy yoon
and [ __ ] um
and dude my uh i was doing uh we wrote
my i was watching you know what i did
every night which was cute dude i'm cute
as [ __ ] man i was watching seinfeld and
friends with my mommy we watched two
episodes of seinfeld and two episodes of
friends didn't we even watch the golden
girls man i'm [ __ ] cute i was
watching it with my mommy so um and this
is how the bed always goes
kristin gets tired she goes upstairs my
dad gets tired he goes upstairs my mom
rides it out with me though dude my mom
rides it the [ __ ] out and then she goes
to bed and then i sit and i watch a
little bit of friends and i realize i'm
lonely and then i go upstairs i go to
bed
so that's how it goes
and i'm just spitting facts right now
dude but that's how it goes
so um
so i'm watching friends and golden girls
and uh seinfeld with my mommy i watch it
with my dad
and my dad was watching friends and he
says still funny
and then i watched sign then he went
upstairs and we watch time for my mom
and uh
and my crystal went up to bed and when
she goes up to bed i go christopher come
here right now and i go
heart palpitating
heart absolutely beaten
ptsd activated
fight or flight mode
i say is everything okay she says yes
but you gotta see this
quel's a little bit still activated okay
i go over to the stairs and she says
look at this
and i see
a spider
that she wants me to kill
but i
probably need a bow and arrow
dude
you know when people are like
i never like when people are like dude i
saw a spider and you're like how big was
it was like huge like that and it never
looks big when they [ __ ] do it with
their hand right and because then you're
like you're always like the body or with
the legs or what and they're like well
the body was this and the legs was this
you're like well were the legs thin or
were they furry you know what i'm
talking about be [ __ ] more specific
i don't do this this is how big the
spider was so i'm gonna tell you right
now you know how the sp how big the
spider was too big and it was big and
then the legs went
okay and it was at the [ __ ] top step
not the floor part but the next step so
i had just started its journey
downstairs to eat us obviously okay or
it wanted to watch friends
we got the [ __ ] friends watching
spider coming down he heard [ __ ] uh
chandler like
you know could i be any more angry and
the friend's like oh his friend's on at
the [ __ ] spot is like who his friends
on
they heard [ __ ] george cassandra's
like oh jerry i don't know and the
spider was like ooh i gotta see it
they heard us still getting be like well
that's because you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] or
whatever and then the [ __ ] spider
came down he likes to watch the golden
girls whatever but it was too big dude
when you see a spider that big you
realize it's naked you know what i'm
talking about it doesn't have clothes
it's so big
wear clothes
put four pair of pants on
so it came down bro it was so big it
looked like i should play frisbee golf
with it and then also the frisbee had
legs on it i mean it was so big dude
so she says you got to kill it and i go
oh
but i've got arachnophobia i've got a
touch of arachnophobia
so i say oh
oh like you know when somebody tells you
to do something you're just so cocked
sure it's not gonna happen right like
you [ __ ] are one of the cogs in
minority report and you're reporting to
her oh well that's actually not what the
future holds though
do you have a [ __ ] flamethrower how
do i kill this spider without burning
the whole house down okay
i mean this party was so big it had
knees
so
i was like oh i can't do this and then
she says come on you got to do it you're
the man and i say not in this house i
say dad
you got to kill this spider i will not
have it any other way she's like hold on
let me plug it in on google maps and i
hear take a right at the stack ice
go up to the [ __ ] stop star
he says i'm coming i'm coming
and then i literally grab calvin's shoe
because i feel you know when like one of
the biggest mistakes you can make but
when killing a spider is grabbing
something too big
people think you need a big thing so you
get a lot of area
like [ __ ] uh
to smash it right but it's always in a
corner of the spider right because the
evolution taught them to be crafty it's
always in the corner like this and you
got to put the book up on the wall and
slide it up like
like you're opening a window from
[ __ ] 1975
and uh and so
i say
i grabbed calvin shoe kristen looks at
me like i'm the spider like what the
[ __ ]
she says you need a bigger shoe it's
like it was like jaws we're gonna need a
bigger boat and i was like really so i
give my my dad walks up and he's smiling
he's like where is it and i say here and
i give him options i give him calvin's
converse and your boy's [ __ ]
yeezy okay i give him my yeezy i don't
want him to use my yeezy because you're
gonna miss it dude
don't use the yeezy you're gonna miss
it's too big it's got a size 13 man
and he says give me that one
about mine and i give it to him and i'm
like you're gonna [ __ ] this up and he
does it dude he [ __ ] smashes the
spider and he did the good thing he
dragged it he smashed it and dragged it
and then um the spider was dead and it
was great and all is well so i was
[ __ ] you know i got a touch of
erectophobia so i watched a little bit
of more friends and golden girls with
mommy and then i went back upstairs to
bed checked the [ __ ] thing for
spiders went slept all good woke up the
next morning in the airbnb too far away
and i'm chilling right and i hear my son
i don't bacon i'm baking i come down and
my my my my um
my son's like sing the bacon song and
i'm like what have i missed my mom sings
a bacon song that's like
bacon
bacon
and calvin's laughing just like i did
right there and then calvin says pop pop
you do it to my dad and my dad says you
want me to sing a bacon song and he says
yeah and my dad goes bacon bacon who's
making bacon
didn't even try
yeah
just said a sentence and stuttered dude
picking picking who's making bacon so
now my my dad's going bacon bacon who's
making bacon way too much dude you know
how much how like toddlers are like do
it again do it again do it again my dad
will do it until the toddler tires out
my dad do you think i read a joke into
the ground oh my god my dad right now is
doing bacon bacon just making who's
making bacon tomatoes [ __ ] my mom
probably
adding lyrics you know calvin's coming
over soon calvin's gonna come over this
week and i got a new i got another
[ __ ] stanza
so i'm coming down and then i e we eat
breakfast and it's too cold because your
boy wakes up lady [ __ ] dude that's what
he does i mean my [ __ ] wife woke me
up at the crack of ten and it's just
like
my dad was up until at six cause he's
got anxiety or some [ __ ] you know he
walks around
too loud
you know making coffee i don't know what
the [ __ ] kind of caught he makes coffee
with a jackhammer
so i got so we we're hanging out for a
little bit and i say you know what i'm
going to do before the [ __ ] rehearsal
dinner i think it was before the wedding
day
i was like i'm going to go get coffee
i'm going to get some [ __ ] tacos i'm
going to bring them back i'm going to
get coffee i'm going to get tacos i'm
going to bring them back because we're
not going to eat for a long time i know
i know how time works about how the
[ __ ] you know
like you know how like you get up and
you're like well we got somewhere to be
so don't fill yourself up i don't dude
[ __ ] all that that anybody who tells you
well we're gonna eat later so don't you
know be ca oh dude
you're never promised
anything though you understand
[ __ ] gets pushed back
people are late you're not going to be
until oh and i did yeah we're going to
eat at the wedding oh the wedding's at
[ __ ] by the way four
no no sorry the wedding's at
four
we got to leave at 2 30. we're not going
to leave till three we're going to be
late and then you don't get to eat right
away right you got to sit through the
wedding right and then get away for the
cocktail to get some extra hors
d'oeuvres and where the hors d'oeuvres
gonna be they're gonna be [ __ ] right
like the only thing that's gonna be of
sustenance really
are like [ __ ] some like dumplings and
you're not gonna get many of them
because that's gonna be the hot [ __ ]
that everybody's gonna be eating so you
could be like we're the dumplings for
like you can just be sitting with like a
quiche a brie quiche and you're like
this doesn't fill me up
i ate six free quiches and i want the
hot [ __ ] but everyone's eating the
dumplings right the girl who works at
[ __ ] spotify ate them all or whatever
the [ __ ]
so you're like okay well [ __ ] man
i'm going to get tacos and my mom's like
well you might not want to fill up and i
go i i live moment to moment dude
okay i live moment to moment and yes i
used to live moment-to-moment more and
that's how i [ __ ] had my whole life
unravel and now i [ __ ] kind of
breathe through it but when it comes to
eating i live [ __ ] moment to moment i
get why people think i'm on cocaine
but um i'm
not and uh
so i go to get the tacos and i get the
[ __ ] coffee coffee's real nice four
shots of espresso i should do a [ __ ]
like a review coffee review like how
that guy does the one bite pizza i
should do the coffee show where i come
out and drink the coffee and if i did it
and i would have [ __ ] what was it
called side
sidekicks coffee in wherever the [ __ ]
would bridge woodland i don't know and
it was good dude you had a good four
shots of espresso i got a chai from my
mom
and then i got wow he's a mama's boy
he's a mommy's boy dude
and uh and then i got i think a mocha
hot thing for my wife it doesn't matter
pick some some [ __ ] coconut pastries
you know how i do it love coconut
flavored [ __ ] when it comes to dessert
when it doesn't come to dessert and when
it comes to meals i'm out count me the
[ __ ] out straight up
coconut rice the [ __ ] out of here they
had coconut rice at the wedding i ate it
but i didn't really want to coconut
macaroons
it's like that drake meme dude
you know coconut rice
coconut macaroons
or whatever the [ __ ] it is with the
big-ass puffy jacket you know missy miss
dominic elliott so and then i come back
with the coffees and tacos
and i'm gonna take a shower and i go up
and i take a shower and guess what dude
i pull back the curtain
the spider's brother
[Music]
so what does this mean
nobody's safe
okay
it's at least as big but it also means
that my mom lied to me growing up and
said if you see one spider you're not
gonna see another one for a while
that's what she said dude my mom would
say [ __ ] like that and then i say it
really like in real life out as an adult
and somebody says i don't think that's
true and i said no no it's true and then
i realized oh my mom was just pacifying
me
i told it to kristen i was like dude if
you see another if she's smile you're
not going to see another spider for a
long time they don't travel like that
she was like that's the exact opposite
of the truth and i go weebay meme oh
i was had
the one the [ __ ] spider's brother
is in the tub dude chilling just like
this
and i go ah [ __ ] that's how i react when
i see a spider always i can't help it
that's what i do i don't scream like a
[ __ ] i don't [ __ ] jump i go ah [ __ ]
because the world
the world got me didn't it
oh you got me oh you just got me oh it
just got me
the qvc guy who [ __ ] banged the
samurai on the desk and then it poked
his liver a piece of that just got me
and then the [ __ ] dub airs guy comes
out we're gonna take a break
oh it just got me like wants to scream
so bad but just oh a piece of that just
got me
so um
god i love you guys i love that you know
what i'm talking about because i've
talked about it so much on this podcast
i don't really want to be making sense
you know i just want to be talking in my
language and have you guys understand
and they say it ain't a cult dude
[Music]
a piece of that just got me
crazy
[Music]
now a word from our sponsor better help
um there are look there's plenty of ways
to support a healthy brain uh like you
can learn a new language or you can take
power naps or drink ginkgo biloba or
whatever that is but uh something that
is really
uh good is therapy and there is a really
great version of it called better help
online therapy and it's easy um i use
therapy
and it's great a lot of times
it it helps me through certain
situations that i feel stressed about
and then sometimes it helps me through
situations that i feel stressed about
that i don't even know i feel stressed
about but i end up feeling you know
overall generally lighter less anxious
and therapy is a really great thing that
i hope that the the stigma um
you know i do think it's changing but i
think like especially more more men uh
feel comfortable getting into it
especially now you can do it on zoom and
that's what better help is better help
is an online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat only therapy
sessions so you don't have to see anyone
on camera if you don't want to um it's
much more affordable than in-person
therapy which is also awesome and you
can be matched with a therapist very
quickly in under 48 hours so listen if
you support the show and you're into
this idea you
for our listeners our listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
congratulations that's betterhelp.com
congratulations so check it out there's
nothing to lose and it's really great
for you so um i stand by that thanks
[Music]
so i was getting my mail earlier today
and uh i was trying to open a package
and i was trying to do it with brute
force and it was so uh stupid that i was
doing this because i did it for a while
before i realized after i ripped it open
that there was a scissors right next to
it i could have just used that and ain't
that just how things go sometimes
don't do things this silly stupid way
the hard way for no reason
it's dumb
and sometimes you can get by doing
things the hard way without realizing it
right
but when you run a business doing things
the hard way means you're holding
yourself and your business back you're
wasting time you're wasting energy so
shipstation
gives ecommerce sellers an easier way to
manage shipping you can take all the
energy that goes into managing orders
choosing carriers and printing labels
and use it to grow your business don't
work stupid
look it's no wonder why ship station is
already trusted by over a hundred
thousand sellers that's a lot of people
you ever see a hundred thousand people
in a room i haven't there's so many
people i don't want to know how much
time i would have wasted if i didn't
have ship station it's quick and easy
ship station will make you wonder why
you never
why why you ever did shipping the hard
way uh it works with all your
storefronts amazon ebay etsy and more
okay so go check it out it helps you
automate the processes like uh
fulfillment and tracking so you can save
time managing orders while keeping all
the customers happy you get deeply
discounted shipping rates normally
reserved for fortune 500 companies so
now basically your fortune 500 company
if you use ship station um
so uh it's all easy to compare and
contrast the rates and uh delivery times
and it's so easy to choose the best
option for every shipping
scenario so uh ship station isn't magic
but it will make your shipping stress
disappear sign up using promo code
congrats for a free 60-day trial today
at shipstation.com that's two months 60
days
and start breathing easier with every
shipment that's two whole months of
stress-free shipping
free
just go to shipstation.com click on the
microphone at the top of the page and
type in congrats ship station make ship
happen
[Music]
so
now the spider's brother shows up dude
and i go god damn it and i'm pissed and
i'm scared but i'm also upset that i
realize my mommy has lied to me
about the spiders and not traveling
together and i've even seen the movie
rock and phobia and there's so many
spiders together and movies tell the
truth so
so i say oh no dad uh you got [ __ ]
got you got it dad you gotta [ __ ]
get the yeezys
and goes okay
let me put it into google maps take a
right go see your [ __ ] son and get a
[ __ ] yeezy shoe take him right up the
bathroom
look in the tub
so
he gets the thing and he kills it the
second now he's a [ __ ] like god he's
a spider killer right now he's like
you know
he's like legit right
so he kills a spider
and then i go thanks
and then i go all right i'm gonna take a
shower and then i realized there's maybe
more spiders around and i say dad i'm
just gonna use your shower like a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and he laughed dude and i did i used his
and i took the towel and i shook it out
before just in case a [ __ ] spider
fell out spider's body just [ __ ] fell
out
and i took the shower and then
and then i looked back into and i [ __ ]
you not the shower i was gonna use with
the spider in it there was another
spider and that is not a lie dude that
was the third fighter i thought now that
was a small spider but that one actually
looked like a black widow and i called
my dad and he [ __ ] got that one too
i'm up three times dude whoa we gotta
bleep that out probably
um
yeah
so anyway dude
like too many sp i saw also other
spiders like outside just just too many
men
clean it up
and that's the thing about airbnbs dude
that's the thing about airbnbs and i'm
not gonna do
airbnbs anymore because when you go to
an airbnb you go into a [ __ ] dormant
place with like spiders or wherever the
[ __ ] you are lizards and [ __ ] are like
when you when families leave they're
like oh [ __ ] this has been quiet for a
while and then they go in and then some
dumbass family comes in like three weeks
later and just shakes the room up and
the spiders are like what the [ __ ] is
going on it's like that scene in [ __ ]
lion king where they're all
you know showing the new king
the circle of life and you're just
trying to take a shower and you got
[ __ ] two eight leggers just looking
up at you this is our [ __ ] place
there's nothing better
or whatever the lyrics are probably
should just be that it probably is that
circle of life
there's nothing better
than the circle of life
just [ __ ] arachnids and lizards and
[ __ ] looking at you there's a koala
peeking out of the [ __ ] cabinet
a crocodile in the pantry a wee mo a
wemo it no that's not [ __ ] whatever
it is
and so i'm [ __ ] scared in this airbnb
and then when i went to the [ __ ]
wedding i went to the wedding and it was
cool and then right as the the guy took
the the officiant took the [ __ ]
whatever you call it
place he was like we're here let's give
a moment of silence or some [ __ ] there
was some moment of silence you know they
do that at weddings they're like this
couple is gonna be married so let's just
not talk for for 40 seconds
and you're just like what
did like soldiers die let's just respect
this family and let's not and let's just
keep our traps shut
and we're going to do it for 40 seconds
and and everyone just does it dude
nah
me in the back
let's practice touching our top lips to
our bottom lips
for the respect of the family we'll do
it for a minute and a half everyone's
just sitting there sweltering in the
heat
me in the back why
so we did it and when we did it as soon
as the silence started calvin says let's
go home
real loud
i laughed hard
little rumblings of laughter and then
afterwards that's all everyone was
talking about i was like well then what
was the [ __ ] laughter [ __ ] right
and the ducks too it was calvin and the
ducks the ducks were in the lake she's
like
make let's go home and i'm like buddy i
feel you but congratulations to my
cousin love ya
uh you got married none of my cousins
are married i'll get my babies
so uh yeah man
so there's love in the air man
everyone's getting married everyone's
getting married because i [ __ ] covet
on all the dates you know got all pushed
back oh get your [ __ ] pushed in
uh
anytime someone says the word push i
think of that all good thanks training
day and so
[Music]
that's one of the top moments of any
cinematic [ __ ]
any cinematic moment of all time i mean
unbelievable oh i saw infinite dude oh
i saw the movie infinite
oh
i saw the movie infinite
oh
i saw the movie infinite and you're
probably thinking what's that movie and
the reason why you're thinking it is the
same reason why i'm talking about it in
this cadence because it's so bad
and that means no one saw it it's so bad
what's the movie well it's mark wahlberg
and the guy from 12 years a slave and
some chick
saw it
wow it's bad
yo it's got 16 percent on rotten
tomatoes and people will be like well
was that the audience score the credit
score and to that i'd say
who gives a [ __ ]
it was so bad dude
i couldn't even believe it mark wahlberg
is first of all
mark wahlberg is a fine actor and i will
tell you this there have been movies
where he's been great
great
actually and there has been movies where
he's been bad and that's fine
those are my favorite kind of actors as
a matter of fact because it means what
they're taking chances or they're bad
and they have good directors either way
i don't care
so i'm watching this movie and i know
mark wahlberg is capable of being a
really great actor but what he's not
capable of doing is being a really good
voice-over actor dude they have
voice-over in the movie and he's just
like they say that when you want to be
live when you die you go to a place and
they say that actually what happens and
everything was and they say that
and some people and they're called the
nihilists and the other people are
called the people that want to live
they're the believers and then the
believers and the nihilists
and when you die you don't just die
and you're just like oh you is morgan
freeman
i don't even give a [ __ ] have morgan
freeman still be that character just
don't have mark wahlberg do the
voiceover too
morgan freeman could pop on and be like
hi just so you know i'm still the morgan
freeman character
but we couldn't have mark wahlberg do
this because it's so [ __ ] weird when
he does voiceovers watch this and then
mark wubble will come on and be like
because there's nihilists and there's
also believers and then morgan freeman
would be like
see
[Laughter]
dude
it's bad
it's so bad dude and antonio fuqua
whatever the [ __ ] his name is dude
anthony fuckwa is [ __ ] directed it
and he did training day oh
[ __ ] pushed in
dude i just realized it's like macho man
randy savage dude
in the the scene in the bathroom where
they're holding the guns on [ __ ]
ethan hawk
get the guy [ __ ] he comes in with a
shotgun it's macho man randy savage
it's not even the mexican guy in the
[ __ ] wife beater it's it's macho man
ready savage with the [ __ ] bandanas
around his biceps for some reason why
was that a thing
you get your [ __ ] pushed in
so how much is [ __ ] what's his name
uh macho man randy savage gonna have a
clip that goes super viral in the next
few months and it's gonna be see
how much is macho man randy savage gonna
have a clip that goes viral in a few
months and the [ __ ] the top of it's
gonna be like uh macho man randy savage
knew all along and it's going to be some
for the 90s and he's going to say
something about [ __ ] current times
i don't need any of you guys i'm having
a blast dude i [ __ ] love it man so
anyway i watched infinite and holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] 16 on rotten tomatoes
whether it's the critics or whether it's
the audience doesn't matter how did it
get 16
should have had less how i'll tell you
right now chinese people in china
watching it that is the only kind of
person who would like that movie and i
don't mean it to be racist i just mean
shit's different over there and they
like [ __ ] cars blasted into outer
space and [ __ ] that's why f [ __ ] tan
are faster than furious the most fast
furious movie
they blasted the car into outer space
and chinese people were just like
in china china got moved here they
realized that's bad
so i'm watching this [ __ ] movie into
infinite and holy [ __ ] mark wahlberg
should never do voice over acting and he
knows it but he did it and i hope he
made a [ __ ] pretty penny off this
[ __ ] and then they got that another guy
[ __ ] chip while china doing it
and then they got some chick i love when
they get the like a really famous dude
in a movie this is when you know movie's
going to be bad i will take it right now
you get
an a-list actor in as the lead
and then as the second lead
you get a guy that nobody knows their
name but they know their face okay like
the trinidad chitwell guy or whatever
the [ __ ] the guy was in 12 years of
slave
but that's not all
then
to to make sure that it's a box office
disaster
you get for the third lead
some check
right like not anna de armas
not [ __ ]
even selena gomez not [ __ ] uh
what's her name
soma hayek only naming latinas but
[ __ ]
someone who's literally some chick and
you're like who the [ __ ] is this and
then you google it and she was in like
[ __ ] season two of the tudors
and you're like oh she's british
bro this movie is so funny it's one of
those movies where they're just like
two people like meet each other and
already they're just like off to the
races in in like they're like in the
eighth year of their relationship where
they just say stuff like
you know what i always thought was funny
and you're just like what you just met
this [ __ ]
and there's definitely that line i don't
know if there is or not because i wasn't
paying attention all the time but when
they say [ __ ] like you're either the
smartest guy i've ever met or the
craziest son of a [ __ ] that ever lived
and then the next guy's like both
so you must be a nihilist
bro this movie is such a rip of the
matrix and i don't like saying that dude
because every movie is a ripped from
everything and it doesn't matter and
dude get that money [ __ ] repurpose
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] like people are
like oh dude this movie is [ __ ] great
it reinvented the wheel no it didn't
dude infinite is the second worst movie
of all time second two of the new matrix
here's why because
it
well it basically tries to be the matrix
and in a horrible way dude they have the
[ __ ] other guy who's the black guy in
it and mark wahlberg is this guy who
doesn't know who he is and they're
trying to tell him he's the guy to save
the [ __ ] world and mark wahlberg's
like no i'm not and then there's like a
[ __ ]
chick that's the trinity girl who kicks
ass and then he has to practice [ __ ]
martial arts in this thing with a guy
that doesn't like him for some reason or
doesn't believe that he's the one just
right off the bat that's one of my
favorite things that movies do like a
guy the lead will meet another guy with
a beard and he'll be like i don't know i
just don't like him just because he's a
beard
and that guy always dies
and at the end right before he dies he's
like
i actually like you
anyway man this movie dude he [ __ ]
takes a motorcycle oh let me just
explain this [ __ ] before i get into it i
know i'm heavy on the [ __ ] infinite
talk because four of you have seen it
but dude
basically everyone keeps
no there's a few people in the world
that have been destined to
reincarnate they don't die they die but
their soul goes to another body and they
just keep going the only way to kill
them is to use this gun
with these special bullets that the
[ __ ] 12 years a slave guy has and he
wants to kill all the infinites because
he is an infinite and he hates being an
infinite and nobody should be an
infinite because you just have to be
reborn and you remember all your past
lives and it's [ __ ] shitty and so
there's an egg that they have to get
that will destroy all of humanity and
the world and it will ruin everyone's
life because there won't be life on
earth anymore and all the infinites will
die okay now he's trying to get this egg
for this to happen because he doesn't
want
this infinite [ __ ] to work anymore and
as he's fighting everybody when he comes
across an infinite he tries to shoot him
with these bullets and what happens at
the end is mark wahlberg wins obviously
by shooting the [ __ ] 12 years of
slave guy with that special bullet and
he dies and you're like oh good now he
saved the
wait a minute why didn't the [ __ ] 12
years ago a slave guy just shoot himself
he would have put himself out of the
misery
the whole movie falls apart
just kill you guy
at the end me and the [ __ ] dude i was
watching it my buddy would go
oh
what the [ __ ]
and mark wahlberg's like guess it was a
nihilist
dude there's one scene where they sh he
shoots his bullet in the back of mark
wahlberg's head and mark wahlberg turns
around and says i'm disappointed in you
you knew i had a metal plate in my head
from my car accident and pulls the
bullet out hey i'm not a play cat stop a
[ __ ] bullet
ah
the screener is like i mean what the
[ __ ] dude
the screenwriter is just like uh
metal plate they go like this
metal plate and then they go
i just put it in
you got to check this movie out dude
when you thought life was over
but there's more lives to live if you're
an infinite
there are nihilists
there are believers
[Music]
at war
i really don't think i'm the guy
you're the guy
mark wahlberg and the guy from 12 years
a slave
and some chick in
prom
infinite
a movie that they tried to bury by
streaming it by having it come out
streaming during covid
so they couldn't actually
so they could hide behind the fact that
it bombed
did it bomb or did it was it covered
though bro
[Music]
gained the system
let's talk about other [ __ ] now i've
talked about only weddings and the movie
infinite
let's do this clip dude holy [ __ ] man
oh my god i wanted to start the episode
with this this lady dude you know i used
to think this kind of [ __ ] was hilarious
and then i realized people are just got
brain problems
but here we go
[ __ ] i'm just trying to help you i'm
sorry but i don't need your help
yes you do [ __ ]
you do you do need my help sir they're
out of cbs
oh threw in the son of a [ __ ] dude okay
i thought those sentences were can't you
see that you son of a [ __ ]
just let me check out my groceries wow
[ __ ] you i'm trying to help you
[ __ ]
i mean you know wow this is you gotta
ask jesus christ i don't have to do
anything
why is she the guy from crosstalk
he's not going to force you to do it
right no no i'm not [ __ ] you
[ __ ] accuse her get the [ __ ] out of
here you [ __ ] accuser um you
[ __ ] accuser
get the [ __ ] out of here oh new
[ __ ] chris farley in the folgers
commercial
chris farley in the folger's commercial
dude
like
what if i told you it wasn't your
regular coffee and it's [ __ ] folgers
you [ __ ] accuser
oh you want your [ __ ] pushed in
user of the [ __ ] brethren you
[ __ ]
yes ma'am
oh and then the lady excuse me yes ma'am
i'm pissed because you won't be calm
i'm busy because you won't repent
oh dude she's in the kids section of a
[ __ ]
uh
ross dress for less
i just want to get some groceries and go
home
no prisoners dude okay so just because
there's religious views don't uh match
with you uh doesn't give you the right
to i don't care
i don't care he's going to hell and you
are too [ __ ]
oh you want your [ __ ]
what's brimstone by the way everyone
always says it you know
so dude
so dutiful hey [ __ ]
dude i'm trying to save your life
[ __ ]
wow unbelievable acholo the way she's
talking [ __ ] i'm just trying to help
you hey poker sorry but i don't need
your help
yes you do [ __ ] wow such a chill
you do you do need my help sir dude so
cholo uh e4e
[Laughter]
a [ __ ] repent dog hey [ __ ]
a [ __ ] pen dog
just [ __ ]
in target just so annoying
a [ __ ]
[ __ ] pin hey he's going to hell
that's why he's going to hell that's why
youtube [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] where the where does
where the toilet paper so hey hey hey
wife get that [ __ ] a [ __ ] you're going
my wife ain't going to hell repent [ __ ]
see she just did it ay get grab the
kleenex and then also get the ring pops
hey [ __ ]
you got the bread
unbelievable you see that you son of a
[ __ ]
so
like the way she's like trying to be
nice but also adding swear words just
don't mix you know i'm trying to help
you don't you see that you son of a
[ __ ]
just let me check out my groceries
i mean the fact that that comes after
that if you're just listening to it hey
[ __ ] a [ __ ] [ __ ] hey
[ __ ] hey [ __ ] i'm just trying
to help you can't you see that you son
of a [ __ ]
ma'am will you just let me check out my
groceries like
dude oh sorry dog
that's my bee
hey dog
repaint dog
143 dog
or whatever the [ __ ] man
don't you know i'm [ __ ] crazy dog
people are insane
wow out of breath um
still don't have my baggage from the
flight in seattle
alaska airlines said it would be here
yesterday morning and then
yesterday at night and then they said it
would be here this morning two times
they lied [ __ ] yeah dude
yes yes dude i don't have my [ __ ]
let's get my airlines dog
come on doc bring my bags man
wow that's so [ __ ] dumb that
gangsters dance like that you know
boogieing
they're buggying
so i don't have my baggage so that's
cool man i was at the [ __ ] thing and
they the thing about alaska airlines is
they're like we guarantee you'll get
your bags in 20 minutes and i go [ __ ]
yeah dude are you kidding me sometimes
you're s
staring at that [ __ ] conveyor belt
and the bags are and it takes like an
hour and [ __ ] you're like i could have
watched braveheart and the whole [ __ ]
thing at least till they cut his [ __ ]
penis off
probably i mean they they you don't
really know they don't show it but they
were kind of [ __ ] balls off
and so uh also just say
the thing
you'll live and it's fine nobody'll
that's that whole [ __ ] pride thing is
so weird back then you know
like i'm watching the tutors and they're
just like
i will not renounce my religion you know
i will not i will not say that king
henry is the is above the church i would
rather die you made it up
i'd rather die than say he's higher than
our church because he's not and i don't
want to die and burn and eternally i i
don't want to i don't want to die and
[ __ ] in brimstone [ __ ]
i don't want to die you made it up
oh they all made up the whole thing
that's hilarious that's the funniest
[ __ ] thing about those times they
just made up everything and then on top
of their made-up rules they made up more
rules
and they were like nah you go by our
rules and the people who made up the
first rules were like no i know this to
be true and the whole thing's made up
it's basically fern gully none of it
exists
and they got i think you got to believe
it because somebody's got a bigger hat
on you know
you gotta believe it because somebody
wears a hat that you can fit a [ __ ]
a baseball player in you know
the whole player up there on top of the
[ __ ] old white dude's head
i mean it's unbelievable
dude i would never have fared back then
they would have been like
are you kidding me i know what i mean to
say is i would have lived the longest
because you're not cut my [ __ ]
nothing off dude
i would be like you need to renounce
your religion and [ __ ] and
say the king is the number one
super supreme holy guy and i would just
be like hey dude hey fam he's the
he's the absolute most holy guy and i
you know what that religion that i went
by and i was raised in that that i said
that i went to that i would go to the
end of the earth for dude i could give a
[ __ ] about that religion i hate it as a
matter of fact today is the day i
realize that what that king is the henry
guy dude he's the number one holy
supreme leader and as a matter of fact i
don't think he's high enough i think
i think and i know nobody's above jesus
but i think if you looked at it in a
certain life you'd figure out that henry
was a little bit above jesus and as a
matter of fact [ __ ] my religion i hated
it always so i'm glad would you want me
to sign yes in my blood fine sure dude i
don't give a [ __ ] you're not chopping
nothing off my head my penis nothing do
you want me to go to jail and stay in a
[ __ ] cave-like thing with limited
light no way dude as a matter of fact
you won't even take my [ __ ] big
leaves that they use to fan people i
will admit [ __ ] anything even if i
didn't do it i don't give a [ __ ] dude
just make me live comfortable
back then it was crazy you'd walk up to
a woman and be like i would like you to
be my mistress is that okay
and they were like oh my god
yes let's get married
and then you have like two three wives
or some [ __ ]
and the wife would be the main wife
would be like god damn it
that's the thing about the [ __ ] times
back then is that queens it was
understood that when a [ __ ] woman was
big with child right that's what they
used to say the most disrespectful way
of all time
shout out to the last episode of a
lifeline it's called big with child go
check it out
but um they would say like you know
the man wanders and that's just kind of
what happens and it's you know you gotta
[ __ ] suck it up and the queen will be
like okay and they know that's the deal
but then when they get married and
they're the queen and they're like oh i
don't want that to happen there's still
that thing so obviously time's changed
and now it's now and
you know everyone preaches monogamy and
that's good but it's like
back then [ __ ] was topsy [ __ ]
turvy dude
just topsy turvy the most topsy is
turviest
ah man
i'll denounce whatever the [ __ ] to keep
my
[ __ ] intact
um but yeah so anyway i don't have my
bags
and so i caught so they said they were
gonna be here last night and then they
said they were going to be here this
morning guess what i need to go and i
knew it too
so it didn't come out i was in the
conveyor belt and it didn't happen and
then i was like waiting and waiting and
then finally
it stops right there's that moment where
the conveyor belt stops it's like two
minutes of the [ __ ] conveyor belt
going and you're like no more packages
just like one box of fish
like you know what i mean that's going
around and you're like who the [ __ ]
brings fish you know it says handled
with care fish
and you're like
and like two car seats
it's like a bucket it's like a [ __ ]
box of fish
frozen fish and then two car seats
wrapped in cellophane and you're like
god damn it is this it and then you just
hear
and it stops and you're like
all right where's the [ __ ] thing
where's the lady i gotta go to in a
small room
and then you go there and you're like hi
can i
and they're like what was it and you're
like there's two bags and like okay i
said does it usually happen the same day
and they're like yeah we'll bring it to
you later on today didn't they called me
said hey you don't need to call back
we'll bring it tomorrow if we don't even
hear from you didn't call him back
didn't hear from me
didn't bring it so now they're supposed
to bring it now
between a half an hour ago and
between six and ten you know too long
dropped my [ __ ] bags off but they
gave me 50 off my next flight but i mean
alaska airflies [ __ ] two places so
let's have another cousin get married in
seattle i don't think i'll be going i
think they go to vancouver too maybe
i'll do that when i do my [ __ ] tour
chrisley.com for tickets i'm not in
vancouver yet but i will be and also i
will be in dallas and wichita and
atlanta and washington dc
[ __ ]
dude this was so funny to me the ben
affleck thing holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
this made me laugh
so
hard dude
that's
ben affleck dude
oh did you think that that was
[Laughter]
oh did you think that was fidel castro
it's the guy
from geely
dude it's so funny that he started
dating jlo again and now he's just like
dude
you know
let it fly when he says madre you know
you got to relax relax the tongue
madre relax a tongue or i shock you like
they're doing handmade style i have that
thing
i don't know j.lo i just ah
marley
no i have the thing from hannah it's the
same thing it's the one they use only a
real version
cattle prod
that's much better do that on the
interview
walk away knocking [ __ ] vases over
with her ass
and at the end she was like jlo he got
home and he was like she was like she
was sitting in dim light and he walked
in and he was and she says he's
stuttered
wow dude that's unbelievable that makes
me laugh so hard and he's just so casual
about it i love ben affleck dude and
he's so casual about it
what's that [ __ ] what's that one that
weird out there
wow so [ __ ] so racist would never fly
now
um what did he say taco gordo or some
[ __ ] wow so dumb um how did he always
get ahead and get so famous so uh
yeah dude
ben affleck rips for real i love ben
affleck god i love ben affleck
what's this one
oh the oh god
this robot thing
hey you like you like having these legs
oh my god you like having your legs back
oh we back it's a snake
she's going with it millions and
millions of years ago hey
hey you like you like having these legs
this [ __ ] snail i mean the snakes in
a tube and it's got four legs on the
tube and the six is in the tube like get
me the [ __ ] out of here hey i'm a snake
can i eat a mouse and the idiot's like
hey hey you like having your legs back
dude the snake's just literal it's so
funny if you just think about literally
the snakes are just sitting there like
this
and it's just moving and he's just like
also a snake
can just move on its own
they don't need legs why are you giving
it to him
they don't need that having your legs
back
she's going with it
wow dude she's going with it i mean
she's trapped
hey guy
she's trapped well how much would that
be a [ __ ]
thing that's a scene from something that
is six seasons on netflix you know
like called like lizard walkers or
forged with mechanics it's called
wow dude
let's look at these [ __ ] dessert the
servant scales oh wow sorry i'm speaking
[ __ ] spanish not to serve it deserve
it um i wonder if i'll get my baggage
back
oh by the way dude subscribe if you like
the pa if you like the uh youtube
subscribe because we changed it to super
cult studios because now we got lifeline
and congratulations and it's the banner
[ __ ] and like obviously i have videos of
my [ __ ] obviously but like
we want it to grow and it's been stuck
at 585.96
for however long because people i think
don't know what super gold is sometimes
you never [ __ ] understand how stupid
people are but it's still me but
subscribe to us and let's break that
[ __ ] man we need to break [ __ ] six
hundred thousand can't do it because we
switched the [ __ ] over and everyone's
like what the [ __ ] is this so do that
like and subscribe this video and leave
a comment it'll help that algorithm you
know what i mean my baby um that's it
for the episode on youtube if you want
to catch the rest of the episode the raw
the uncut unedited episode go on over to
patreon.comcrystalia
and listen here
for only six dollars a month you get the
rest of all the episodes and you also
get one extra episode a month
uh which now is like 15 episodes just go
ahead and stream it go ahead and [ __ ]
binge it like it's [ __ ] breaking bad
patreon.com and then also i did another
podcast with kristin it's on there if
you want to see a little bit of how the
family works and i do another thing
called review mode that comes out uh
every month dude it's all
gangbusters patreon.com crystal
thank you very much
[Music]
you